لا تملك بريطانيا رفاهيه رفض حضور قمه
تناقش احدى اكثر الملفات انذارا بالخطر
على العالم هذا ما عبر عنه العديد من ناشط
البيئه الذين انتقدوا تردد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الجديد في حضور قمه شرم الشيخ
المناخيه قبل ان يعود للتراجع عن قراره
بعد اتداح ان اتخاذ قرار كهذا قد يحسب
سلبا على مسيرته السياسيه
وهو ما يلقي بعض الشك على ان الحكومه تفهم
او لا تملك بالاحرى فهما واضحا بشان مدى
اهميه قضيه التغيير المناخي
تراجع عن اعتبرته المعارضه انه جاء تحت
ضغوط سياسيه لا على اساس قرارات قياديه
وتعد ازمه المناخ من اكثر الملفات الحاحا
في بريطانيا التي شهدت خلال الصيف موجات
حر لم يسجل مثلها في تاريخ البلاد والتي
تسببت بجفاف قد تمتد تداعياته لعقود قادمه
كما ان ارتفاع درجات الحراره عن معدلها
المعتاد هذا الخريف يشير الى تسارع وتيره
الاحتباس الحراري
المملكه المتحده مثل الكثير من الدول
تواجه تحديات ملحوظه بالنسبه لنا بتحديد
ارتفاع درجات الحراره كما اننا سجلنا
ارتفاعا في عدد الوفيات هذا الصيف بسبب
موجه الحر وتاثيرات الامطار والفيضانات
وهو ما دفع مئات الناشطين الى الشوارع
احتجاجا على عجز الحكومه عن اتخاذ
السياسات للحد من الظواهر البيئيه ما يجعل
خلافات الحكومه تشويشا على ملفات تعد اكثر
اهميه بالنسبه للبريطانيين ههه
يريدون افعالا الناس تريد من الحكومه ان
تكون متماسكه وان تنجز الاولويات التي
يطالبون بها
بريطانيا الرائد في مجال مكافحه التغير
المناخي والذي شهد تحول النوعيا العام
الماضي في قمه كابتن تي 6 جعل من حضورها
في قمه هذا العام امرا ضروريا بالنسبه
للبريطانيين الذين ترى الاغلبيه منهم ان
ازمه المناخ ليست ثانويه مهما ساءت
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها بريطانيا
من منظر عروب عبد الحق العربيه